[Applause]
who
are upset the government is slowly like
giving them less money
i mean i i understand a good question al
i understand the people that go
you're telling me i gotta shut down my
business
and you're not gonna give me any money
like let me at least try to make my
business compliant you know like in new
york
in long island governor cuomo shut down
outdoor events that were socially
distanced with masks
what the [ __ ] do you want from us bro
yeah it's like
we're complying with everything yeah and
you're still gonna shut it down
you can't you gotta let these people
make a living you gotta let them try if
you give them the rules
and they find a way to operate around
your rules
let them give it a [ __ ] try yeah what
about the complaints on people
say that there are some people
are making more money from the
money the government was giving and
unemployment so be it
nothing no system is going to be perfect
and there are a lot of people making
more money
right and so be it then it is impossible
to like
carve out the exact amount of money that
every single person should get based on
how much they've
like you have to just kind of do this
blanket thing you have to kind of
understand that you don't want to just
give too much money away print too much
money because then inflation could get
crazy i guess
i'm not an economist but i also like
listen let's be honest there was like a
trillion plus dollar bank bailout
12 years ago that's like 4 000
for every human being in america man
woman child so like
we're just we're doing it a little bit
differently maybe it's costing a little
bit more but we've done this before
yeah printed money to give people before
and now we're just giving it to people
my concern with the businesses is just
like
if you tell them the rules and they find
a way to operate around the rules
don't continue to shut them down yeah
you know especially when cases are super
low
like when i mean like just let them
[ __ ] try
that's what i don't like when you just
snip their feathers so they can't even
fly like let them [ __ ] try
if you say you got to be outside you say
you have to be six feet apart
you say you have to have all these
screens up just give us all the rules
then let me find a way to win with those
rules i'll find a way to win
but every time i try to find a way win
you shut down again now i'm pissed off
at the government because now it seems
like you're not even gonna try and
you're cutting the funding
and you're gonna cut funding you you're
gonna literally throw my life's work
away
it's not me but i imagine it's a
restaurant or something you can throw my
life's work away
for for something i'm complying with and
then when there's a protest and don't
get me wrong we support the protests but
when there's a protest you're like oh no
people should be able to peacefully
protest
because you want their votes like that
is where you have to understand the
business owner is upset
they should be able to protest and i
should be able to conduct businesses
that
as i as forfeiting your rules or
whatever as fit your old rules when the
pandemic was crazier
yeah man i mean that [ __ ] is just corny
and i understand you're doing it to like
save people
etc but like are you really bro i mean
that would that would be their argument
that would be their argument reelected
yeah i think they're just trying to get
reelected so they're like okay we got to
keep numbers down in every way possible
so that i can get
re-elected and maybe i don't care about
those small business owners that are
probably going to vote republican
because
they appreciate the republican tax
incentives
way more than democratic ones so i'm
already not getting their vote so [ __ ]
that business
i literally think that's what it is
where the black guys matter protesters
are like no
i need them to support me because i'm a
liberal uh
governor i'm a liberal mayor i'm
whatever it is i need them support so
whatever they want to do
will allow that and that's really okay i
would imagine there are way less rules
on small businesses in republican uh
governed states
oh there are is that true what do you
mean in terms of like businesses
operating restaurants having outdoor
seating
texas opened up so fast that's why case
has spiked in a lot of those states
yeah but there's a there is a happy
medium i thought the way new york
handled it
for a long time was really good now
though as cases are
really low you can open things up slowly
right i don't think you could you don't
need to be arrogant
that's the thing i'm saying it's like
they closed down governor's island when
they were doing
not governor's uh governor's comedy club
on long island when they were doing for
tim dillon's show when they were doing
outdoor
socially distance seating we just did
that exact same show in new jersey yeah
that's the one rule i
don't understand but they are slowly
opening stuff like gyms are supposed to
be open next week
good so it's like they're slowly opening
stuff
again it's just maybe there's something
they realize that oh with these outdoor
situations it's still
if it's tented and people are still too
close like i'm sure there's a reason why
of course there's a reason all of a
sudden we can't do that i just think
that that reason is
is manipulated by politics and i don't
even think go he's just trying to get
reelected i think cuomo got his eyes on
the white house in 2024 yeah
so this is not eve this is like i'm the
hard nose whatev whatever he's trying to
present himself as 2024 these are the
things he's putting in place now
yeah but and trust me i'm really not
arguing for their side i can just see
their
motive behind it because it's like hey
if i'm doing this for re-election i'm
also doing this to save lives
i don't know that because i feel like
there's other things you could have done
to save lives no but i mean like the
strict
so why don't you think that why do you
think they're totally cool with all the
protests
because that would impinge on people's
uh
you know right um protest or whatever so
it's like that you could very easily say
a comedy show is freedom of expression
you could also say you have the freedom
to make a living and you're removing
their right to make a living
i understand then they say oh and we're
supplementing your income with
not doing enough yeah now you're
reducing it yeah do you think that like
the conservative governors in places
like florida or texas are also just
trying to get re-elected by
yeah businesses i don't think they're
just as hypocrites everybody panders to
their fan base so
sorry go no i just imagine that in
florida a lot of the business owners are
probably more happy than they are
maybe up here 100 because they're like
yeah i'm still making money i'm still
open like
i think i think that cuomo is like i'm
okay if some black people die
or some white people die or whoever's
going to black lives matter protest die
or their grandparents die
just as so the majority of those people
with those protests vote for me
happy with me they're happy with me and
i think that the governor of florida is
like i'm okay with some restaurant goers
die or their grandparents die
or some small business owners die just
as just so that
the majority of the people there will
vote for me and i think
honestly it sounds sociopathic to think
of and it probably is but that
are that is the type of decision that
you have to make as a governor every
decision you make
you got to be a little sociopathic yeah
i also think
this is probably i haven't thought this
through enough but like i don't like
re-electing
officials i don't think they should have
that option you get six years eight
years whatever you want but you get your
one term
so you don't spend the whole term just
trying to get re-elected because that's
all they do the entire time in office
yeah oh these guys vote let me make them
happy these guys will
make them happy you could argue though
that there's like an efficiency
um there's an efficiency problem with
that like and they say that sometimes
with like the where
the american workflow which is like the
second you get good at your job you're
promoted
yeah and now the person replaces you
isn't as good as you were
that's why i would be in favor of
extending it from four years to six or
eight or whatever it made i don't know
it almost like
fits the cast system perfectly it's like
well yeah you just stay there
yeah and you do that thing yeah and you
get amazing at that thing
yeah and then it will be the most
efficient and then these people do this
thing and they'll get amazing that thing
and they'll be the most efficient
i like the way you tried to make me feel
that [ __ ]
and i wanted to be on board real bad
well i mean it was the british idea it
was all right
we thought we tried out with you guys
you know but not uh you understand what
i'm saying so like
some people might argue i completely
understand like especially these [ __ ]
congress
congressmen that have two years since uh
what is it called two year terms
yeah and they spend the entire two years
just trying to get re-elected it's like
you're not going to join
them at all yeah exactly that being said
like there is something to say
okay you did four years you understand
how the system works you understand
government you built up these
relationships
maybe you can get more done in your
second term who knows i think the idea
is you
that way you're always kind of trying to
prove yourself and then you can get
reelected
but the flaw in that to me is most
people don't vote so those guys just
prove themselves to the one who do
but if you just had your one term i want
you to have a vision and see that vision
through
let's see what you got i feel you man i
feel as far as businesses go it's like
yo
you got to decide what the [ __ ] the
rules are if we can't be inside fine
but let businesses figure out how to
operate within the rules
yeah and if you keep on removing their
ability to function and rebuild in their
ability to operate they have every right
to be absolutely furious with you
because it seems like an attack on them
and their livelihood and their families
particularly with live performance
that's such a part of new york
like that's a thing people move here for
us to be a jazz musician a stand-up
comic like this is a
part of the economy that exists here and
really only here but like
that's what that's a draw for your city
you can't shut that [ __ ] up i don't i
don't understand there's literally
a person with a microphone yelling
things into it as people
outside watch and support
did i just describe a protest or a
comedy show yeah
it's the same well are they socially
because if they're not socially
distanced is approaching then it's a
protest if they're socially disintended
it's actually potentially safer like
what the [ __ ]
yeah maybe not as important but safer it
isn't as important yeah it's comedy it's
fun
yeah but it is undeniably safer and if
these rules are to keep people safe not
to get people re-elected
then you should allow it to happen am i
am i being absurd here
no i mean you just say that oh comedy
shows aren't essential
protests are an essential thing yeah
and so we're just cutting out all the
non-essential stuff anything that not
essential
we're going to criticize everything
essential will sort of all right so they
then stop serving alcohol that's not
essential
you